the number of people worldwide who've
died from coronavirus-related deaths has
topped
one million and even with that figure
the true number of cases is likely to be
higher still because of the number of
cases that go
undetected these are the latest figures
from the johns hopkins university
tracker you can see that figures already
soared beyond
the 1 million mark within the past
couple of hours
the number of recorded infections is now
more than 33
million the us brazil and india make up
more than 50 percent
of those cases and those three countries
also account
for nearly half of all global debts
well the u.n secretary general has been
reacting to what he called a
mind-numbing figure
but antonio guterres also called on the
world's not to lose
hope and urged people to continue
observing necessary precautions
to curb the spread of the virus our
world has reached an agonizing milestone
the loss of one million lives from the
covet-19 pandemic
it's a mind-numbing figure yet we must
never lose sight of each and every
individual life
they were fathers and mothers wives and
husbands brothers and sisters
friends and colleagues the pain has been
multiplied by the savageness of this
disease
risks of infection kept families from
bad sides
and the process of mourning and
celebrating a life was often made
impossible
well the u.s remains the worst affected
nation heidi joe castro has more from
silver spring
in maryland out of these one million
plus
deaths worldwide we know that at least
one in five were deaths
due to covet here in the united states
the u.s total death toll still
far surpassing that of any other country
in the world public health officials
here are also concerned now
that although things seem to be under
control to an extent they're fearful
of a second wave and they're looking
particularly at places like new york
city
which saw catastrophic losses of life in
april
then seeming to contain the virus
successfully
only to have new hot spots
flaring up in these days that we're
experiencing now
president trump though saying that this
nation is turning a corner
on the pandemic he hosted a rose garden
event at the white house today in which
he announced
the distribution of 150 million
rapid covet diagnostic tests they would
produce results he say
he says within 15 minutes 50 million are
going toward vulnerable communities
including
nursing homes the remaining 100 million
to states
and territories to be given out in
schools
and in work settings last week we
crossed a historic milestone
when the united states conducted our 100
millionth
test far more than any other country
and not even close actually second seems
to be
india with 1.5 billion people and the
numbers would be
probably at least 50 million more tests
by us
we've conducted more tests than the
entire european union and
more than all of latin america combined
this is not the deep brain biopsy that
we talk about
this will generally done by a health
care provider but it can be done
supervised it's this easy one
two three four five one two three four
five into the test twisted three times
the adhesive is pulled off and you wait
15 minutes
and that is the test it really could not
be easier than this
this is a very sophisticated little
piece of cardboard with lots of
antibodies and incredible technology
into that
well you break through tests they're
being announced at the white house but
despite
all the testing uh and the claims uh by
the u.s
president one in five of the
world's coronavirus deaths have been in
the united states now the daily death
toll is
on the decline there but there has been
another surge
in you infections and with it fears of a
second wave
kristen salumi has more
anthony and rosemary terrio were married
for 65 years
they died in new york five days apart
during the peak of the coronavirus
pandemic
they met when my mom was like 17
and they were together ever since they
moved to queens
in oh gosh right after they got married
the disease has made its way through new
york in the tario family
now it is the midwestern united states
that are seeing the most new cases
which are on the rise for the first time
in eight weeks as the nationwide death
toll tops two hundred thousand
eight family members had it you know it
just it went
the whole gamut my my sister was taking
care of my mother
she caught it then she gave it to her
son and
her son gave it to his partner and my
my brother gave it to his wife and my
other brother caught it and gave it to
his wife
while the other family members have
recovered the impact of the disease is
still being felt
experts attribute the recent spike on
the reopening of schools and
universities
as well as large end of summer
gatherings but the terrios
also blame politicians and ordinary
people across the country
they feel aren't doing enough to stop
the spread
it's just i'm seeing so much uh
um people not you know being
careless with wearing a mask and they
can save a life
there are so many other old people that
are i don't want
this to happen to them when they can
just be responsible
and not complacent with um something
that they may survive but
and it doesn't necessarily have to be an
old person it could be
a woman battling lung you know breast
cancer or a little a child battling
leukemia
or something like that and it's just a
mask
you know for a few minutes a family
struggling with loss
and hoping that amid the uncertainties
of a pandemic
others can be spared their pain kristen
salumi al jazeera
new york